so in this video i'll be talking about
how to manage being a student and doing
only fans
um so i guess the main thing would be
about time management and because only
fans actually does take a lot of time
and it is very time consuming
so as you probably might not know i am a
mechanical engineering student at an ivy
league university obviously i'm not
going to say which one
but that also does come with a lot of
work so putting only fans on top of that
just does become a big hassle this
religion is not your sales pitch
it is not your marketing strategy to
gain more followers and more money and
more income this is not this is not a
game this is not something you should
try and play with
you know i advise you sincerely to be
careful what you're doing don't don't
play with the religion of allah there's
a lot in the dunya there's a lot in the
world that you can play with this is not
one of the things that you should toy
around with
three muslims we got our american over
here who was one of our first guests
good to be back let me just say real
quick i don't wanna hijack it but it's
beautiful to see your brothers take off
to see you your brother's going places
remember when we first spoke i told you
if you did it you blow up and mashallah
my prediction was correct
i'm gonna love bro hello my body bro
and for everything you did to help us
man may allah bless you
why yeah
i mean
have you noticed that there are no
female prophets according to our
religion we only have male prophets it
makes you wonder is god sexist or
something let me know what you think in
the comments salaam step 1 be a male
since it seems god does not accept
female applications
step 2 don't fully contradict the
established religion but instead tell
people you came to improve their
previous religions because you have
received some new updates from god
step 3 pretend to receive revelations
from god by an angel or you can pretend
to be god himself
step 4 since rich people don't need you
promise poor people they will be
rewarded in the afterlife
and step 5 win major battles and set
laws that prohibit criticism of the
religion
remember history is written by the
victorious so don't worry any
actions or war crimes you have committed
will be justified since people don't
dare to question the validity of your
actions they'll inherit the religion
from their family and even defend you in
the comments section of this video
unfortunately in certain
hold up bro hold up
listen i don't want to make any
justifications here but
what she's saying takes out of the fold
of islam and allah knows best but i mean
you can't disbelief
the in the prophets peace be upon them
all
you you can't disbelieve that
these are major statements of the
statements of major kuffer there are
statements of major disbelief
that's pretty hefty stuff
um
there's a comment section on one of my
videos they're talking about her they
say she's non-muslim but it was him it
was a matter of him making tech fear so
i don't know maybe she's just playing a
muslim card maybe she comes from a
muslim family and
she's taking that whole get popular off
the ex muslim route i don't know what's
going on with her but yeah those are
some serious uh
statements of this belief right there
i mean allah says in the quran like if
you
disbelieve
in
one of the prophets is if you disbelieve
in all the prophets
like
at that point like are you are you even
a muslim like
do you even believe in what allah is
bringing down because the prophets are
just the messengers of allah
yeah
but let's let's address what she
actually said she said a lot and a lot
of nonsensical stuff and she had this
really orientalist-like narrative which
is honestly very funny that she's you
know wearing the hijab and saying all
this nonsense which is obviously the
irony of it but the whole you know it's
god's sexist thing because all the men
were prophets first and foremost
the the roles of the prophets
were the most difficult roles
and allah created the men
to do the more difficult roles the more
physically uh demanding roles and roles
that you have to forbear a lot more it's
for the men i don't know why that is a
problem because uh if a man comes and he
puts all this work onto a woman then
that man is sexist but now if a man
comes and doesn't put all that work into
a woman the man's sexist so
you like you can't
you can't have the cake and eat it at
the same time it's i think it's a mercy
and if you look at the women mentioned
in the quran like the wife of iran
was a disgusting person
the angels
kicked dirt into his mouth when he was
dying so he wouldn't say the shahada so
he wouldn't try and become a muslim at
the time
that's how dirty it was his wife
may allah be pleased with her and have
mercy on her i mean was one of the most
amazing women who have lived and she was
mentioned in the quran look at um
as entire surah in the quran dedicated
to her so if
islam was the first religion to actually
establish women's rights so if you were
going to go with this narrative get the
facts straight you said history is
written by the victorious
muslims were victorious and we have the
history documented and if you truly read
into it
you wouldn't be spearing this nonsense
that you spoke now
you make a good point
i mean you have to imagine how the arabs
of the times were before islam came they
buried their daughters alive
you know
and um so i mean but her charge isn't
really against islam it's more against
allah himself
saying is he sexist you know because all
the prophets and the messengers are men
i mean
you know
i don't consider myself a study person
but i can look at people and their
behaviors and i can honestly say that
what i've seen is that throughout
history men have always gone against the
grain they've always had that inner
strength to fight the battles that
needed to be fought the guy i forgot his
name
and it might seem off topic but it's not
but the guy who who like first
discovered polio or something like this
i can't remember where he was and he was
talking about infectious diseases they
put him in an insane asylum until he
died and then later he was confirmed as
like um
as just a genius ahead of his time
but what we see in history also is that
a lot of times when it comes to pressure
women start to comply they bend you know
they start to wax and wane and they they
they take the easier route
i think this thing would like you know
this internal battle with the external
world because it is an internal battle
to actually just go against the brain
this is something that's like almost
uniquely male and that's not to trash
women absolutely not
we know that you know uh this is why
women like strong men because these the
men fight the battles for the women so i
don't know why this is a problem
it's like how we were created this is
just how it
is i agree imagine imagine allah stuck
for allah sending women as prophets and
they're supposed to be the imam but they
can't even pray one week of the month
bro
like that alone should be suffice
but allah
all right let's get back in yeah you're
gonna say something bro
i think both of us were gonna say
something
but um
it's sad man and it's kind of dangerous
you know like the more i think about it
the more i'm like coming to the
conclusion that
this woman probably doesn't have that
much understanding of
this religion that she says that she
follows that she's a part of
because like what she's saying it's
it's a lot of ignorance behind it and
it's dangerous that someone that doesn't
have knowledge and
and has uh the ability to
be able to be heard and be seen by so
many people who will take what she's
saying
as like the truth now
you know so it's like she is an ignorant
so now she's going to lead others in
ignorance
and like she is astray from what she is
saying
and like that's a heavy claim to make
but she is astray and she's leading
others astray so it's sad
and it's dangerous
and can i have another point that you
brought to my attention it's like that
what she's saying here and that so many
women are like so mad at men just in
general for being men
it's maybe a proof that they shouldn't
be in leadership i mean why are you
getting upset over something so
so simplistic you know i could get upset
that no prophets or messengers were
there black prophets and messengers
actually there might have been
but you know you know i'm saying we
could break this down on every level
from every ethnicity to whatever else it
just doesn't you know why were there no
blond prophets or whatever else
people aren't getting mad about this
stuff but you're getting mad about this
maybe it's a proof on its own i don't
know
maybe that's what's true
yeah and something i wanna i wanna add
here just my final notes on this topic
is uh if you especially if you look at
how people lived before
this you know vast technological events
before modernity basically um they had
very very clear gender roles very clear
the men were always doing the hunting
the gathering the heavy lifting the
heavy work all the things that honestly
are predominantly just outside the home
the men were doing them and the women
were predominantly taking care of the
kids and taking care of the house and
all of that and there's no problem with
that that's how it was so especially if
you forego this fallacy of presentism
when you look at the past with your
present mindset and worldly view
and apply it to them when you forget
that then you'll realize there's
actually absolutely no problem with that
and finally what i want to say
is uh there's actually a woman who went
to the prophet
and she asked about how allah is always
referencing uh like basically the the
male plural because when you say the
male plural in arabic the masculine
plural it includes it could include
everyone it could include women as well
like if you have a group of people and
there's like
a few men and a few women you would use
the masculine pronoun and it would it
would mention all of them so she asked
what like is allah talking only about
the men does it include women what's up
with that and then allah revealed the
verses
the believing men and the believing
women the muslim men and the muslim
women the patient men the patient women
the fasting men fasting women so on and
so forth and he ends it by saying that
we'll all have basically a reward from
allah
so this whole thing of sexism and all
that stuff
has no place in his life
look for allah you're right and john is
at the feet of our mothers bro so
not much else to say on that
verse 34 in the quran the husband is
allowed to beat his wife if she becomes
disobedient
this is seen in the part of the verse
which is translated to as for women whom
you fear disobedience advise them and
leave them apart in their beds and them
i'm not sure why god would allow men to
punish women this way is this really
fair let me know what you think
i love the whole is this really fair let
me know what you guys think like like
salaam
she doesn't even mention the otterbee at
all because when you say beat
beats only basically only has one
meaning that it's like a physical like
beating because you can beat someone
um
and beating kind of has a connotation
that you're beating on them it's not
just one like little like you know that
it's beating it's like physical like
what happens in a boxing meeting but in
arabic it's it's
kind of like adorable is what others say
nowadays
uh it could it just means kind of like a
hit and it could be light it could be
hard it could be the stuff the other so
then we go to the prophet
the sahaba and the scholars what do they
say about it
she narrated with the prophet saw he
said never hit a woman or even an animal
right on top of that on top of that the
prophet himself said never he hit or or
never hit or harm the female servants of
god
so
now the wife of the prophet
that's all i said specifically these
other prophets never hit women if you go
to the i believe in abbas
he said that this is supposed to be a
symbol of divorce a signal which is
basically talk when you do this to a
woman it's like signaling you're gonna
divorce her and if you say the lock
three times it's a final divorce that's
why it's the final straw it's basically
saying listen i can't put up with this
anymore i've been advising you i left
the bed you won't listen to me at this
point i'm getting close to divorcing you
that's literally what i'm saying and
everything cathedral of illinois he
wrote the same thing as tafsir so on and
so forth but since you're very unlearned
and you're very islamophobic i don't
care if you're the hijab you're an
islamophobe and you're clearly a
non-muslim from what you say
and we invite you back to islam
wholeheartedly
basically get off that thai horse of
what do you guys think i think what i
think you're full of nonsense honestly
what about you bro
it was pretty slick how she pulled that
whole
uh uh
admonish her and beat her
and abandon the bed when it's actually a
three-phase it's like a three-step thing
so if she's disobedient then first you
admonish her admonishing i think
everyone i don't know if we need a
translation but anybody who's in
confusion that means you tell her that
she's wrong you advise her you know and
say hey look you know what you're doing
is wrong to say correct you should
really change your behavior for the
better
then the next phase is if that is not if
that doesn't bring a response is you
abandon the bed with her
you know you so you separate yourself
from and we all know women love
attention they like being you know
together with the man so you separate
yourself from her especially the bed the
bed is the place where focused
one-to-one attention takes place so you
remove this from her
and you have to especially think about
the times
that this revelation came down a woman
had no external attention like they do
with their phones and internet whatever
right now so to cut a woman off of
attention like that that was very very
powerful you know today she can just you
know you ignore your woman she gets on
the phone and she's got you know 10 000
people on there from females to males
trying to give her attention it might
not be so powerful this day but it's
still the chain that you follow and then
finally
if all else fails
then
then you attempt the beating and i heard
one one student of knowledge say that
this is symbolic because we know that uh
the messenger of allah peace be upon him
he was very specific you know uh with
revelation and he said you could beat
her with a miswax stick misway stick is
roughly when they're big about the size
of your finger and maybe as long as a
cell phone
and so he's saying symbolic like i have
power over you if i was so inclined to i
could just i could thrash you
but i'm taking this miswak stick which
we all know
who when we've used one you can't hurt
anybody with it unless maybe you try and
stab him in the eye with it
which obviously is not intended by that
you know so
it's symbolic like it's just to
demonstrate i do have power review
there's nothing you can do about it if i
wanted to beat you
this is another interpretation of it so
i like how she though she removes that
she just says you know admonish her and
abandon the bed and beat her like if
it's just this three-phase thing you're
doing just all at once just
it's like top wheel of it's it's really
it's it's a type of top wheel really it
is it's a really it's a type of tattoo
i agree and when you go to like
ex-muslims or islamophobe central on
youtube you'll see david wood apostles
and all these people and and this
argument that she brought up surrounding
verse 4 uh verse 34 from chapter four
this is like one of the common textbook
things on that list so it's almost like
she just went to like biggest signs
islam is false or something and just
pull this out of thin air
again man the only thing i have to say
is
you can tell
you can tell she doesn't really know the
religion
she hasn't studied it
she hasn't even reflected on these
things so
it's a shame it's sad and it's dangerous
i'm gonna stick to that but let's see
what's next
there's a consensus amongst muslim
scholars that muhammad had nine official
wives simultaneously at the time before
he died
most people think that the quran allows
only four wives but actually there's no
limit
one of his wives at the time was zainab
who was actually his daughter-in-law
in addition to these nine wives muhammad
also had three concubines or slaves
which he was allowed to have sexual
relations with according to the quran in
surat al-mu'min
one of the slaves he used to have sexual
relations with was maria al-kaptiya
she was given to him by egypt's
christian governor because he was scared
of muhammad's invasion after he invited
the governor to islam
i absolutely love the freedom that islam
gave to men but i wish we as women were
also given the same freedom in having
multiple husbands or at least having a
concubine
nah nah bro you're stupid like i hate to
say it bro and and you know anyone
watching this that that thinks i'm an
able for this listen if you got two
brain cells and you think this is really
what what islam is about why are you
still wearing a hijab and why are you
still muslim then that's my question
like if this is really how you feel and
this is this is what you've come to why
are you still here
identifying with islam and looking like
a muslim you're not a muslim bro makes
no sense
yeah and i mean obviously we're not
advising anyone to take off the hijab
because we believe that you know all
women
doesn't matter
but uh basically if you just keep quiet
about them honestly unless you you have
a platform and you invite a muslim on to
challenge your views uh don't talk about
that wholeheartedly um subhanallah like
bro
this feels like a circus man a lot of
the things she's saying but um this just
shows how unlearned she is look at the
prophet saddam there are certain things
he was allowed to do that
everyone else was allowed to do because
he's a prophet there are certain things
he had to do that other people didn't
have to do because he's a prophet for
example night prayer was obligatory for
the prophet he was obligated to wake up
every night and pray every single night
when you and i are not obligated to and
that's a blessing and mercy from allah
for us and for him
and even one sahabah once sahabi tried
to do that until his feet started to
crack or i believe that was actually the
process of his feast or the crack but he
actually specifically told the the
sahaba not to do it for as long as he
did it because he was a prophet
so for you to come be like oh he had
nine wives but the quran says for this
was literally an exception from allah
we had obligations that we don't have he
had things he had rights that we didn't
have and even the process of himself
said that he has the strength of many
men of multiple men because he's the
prophet of allah and you know regular
men just don't have that
i'm going to
by the way i just want to say uh there
is one more clip we got but uh
what you thought
i mean i think that she she
misunderstands a lot the messenger of a
lot of people was an example
you know and he was an example for us to
follow
he his his why he came down in the in
the second half of his life
so to demonstrate the women that you
could marry it was just an inevitability
now you know that he would have to marry
more than four wives to demonstrate that
you could marry the the widow you could
marry this one you could marry divorcees
you could marry that one you could marry
the young woman you could you know how
is he supposed to do all this he didn't
get why he when he was 19
and then died when he was 60 or
something you know it came to him later
in his life and so obviously
he was
brown now
obviously you can argue with me say
about america i've never heard this
before but i mean it's just logical
sense if you just use your just basic
brain just like you said earlier if you
rub two brain cells together this makes
perfect sense there was a limited amount
of time in his lifetime you know and so
he's being the example to mankind you
can now see okay ah i can do this i can
do that oh i can even marry multiple
women also you know but there's a limit
and the why he came to him also that he
that there was a time when he was not
allowed to marry any more women period
if one died if they all died that was it
for him
you know so
and then just this whole thing with
slavery i don't want to get into what uh
what about ism i don't want to get into
it but let's just face the facts this
goes back to what romney was saying
earlier about
trying to compare times back then to
times now
and we're not we're not ashamed of and
we don't deny that that slavery is a
part of islam we're not ashamed of it
this this is how it is this is how it
was
but this has been all of mankind this
has been a fixture from the aztecs to
the europeans
how did my people get to america
why are there light-skinned
african-americans because the people
used to go and rape the slaves and
whatever else
it was brutal then what muslims though
what what do we say with the slaves they
wear what we wear they eat what we eat
we treat them well
they're not people like we know slavery
or in the west
it's not the same islam you are to treat
your slaves well they are like family
yes they are not free people but they
wear the clothes that you wear
they eat the food that you eat
correct yeah sorry go ahead no i was
gonna say someone can correct me if i'm
wrong too but even the concubine thing
she said if you impregnate a concubine i
believe you have to marry her
islamically
you know and and
yeah so someone can can fact-check that
but that's what i what i've seen from my
research so islam gives women rights
it's not slavery in the western sense
too so i don't know what she's on about
yeah but that's what you're trying to do
she's trying to equate it to that put
this horror picture in the minds of
people
yeah 100 and subhan allah like i
nowadays i refuse to even use the term
slavery because if you look at what
slavery is islam does not allows like
that term slavery especially with the
economy we have nowadays islam allows
um
prisoners of war because if you think
about it you are you know you have your
nation you have another nation you don't
have prison systems
either you a let the enemies go which
they're just gonna come back and try and
kill you stronger and know your plans
and everything or two you kill them all
which is obviously the worst option if
they're said if they're surrendering
after fighting you or three you take
them as prisoners of war they didn't
have prison systems so what they did is
they imprison them in their homes the
only way to keep them imprisoned in your
home is either tie them to something or
let them be but they act as a servant
essentially and as abu americans said
yes
they they eat what you eat they wear
what you wear and we even got rid of the
term master and servant or master and
slave they literally they change the
wording to body and body that's
literally they change the wording for us
because with the only rob the only lord
is allah and we're all his slaves
essentially that's how specific islam is
about this this concept of servitude now
i'm going to combine the topic of
multiple husband-slash-wives
to the topic of um
uh allowing men being allowed to be
intimate with with the female
servants not even going to call them
slaves
because it has basically it's one big
topic
think about a woman who has multiple
husbands
if a woman can only be pregnant once a
year
and she only wants two kids she has four
husbands
if if two of them are lucky they're
gonna have a kid and if one is super
lucky if he's gonna have two and the
other three are gonna have none on top
of that i you really want to talk about
sexual freedoms and all of that but you
want a woman to have to put up with
sleeping with multiple men who all have
a higher sex drive than her
does that make sense especially when she
gets pregnant does that make sense
and if she can't what happens uh with
the men uh the four different men with
this high sex drive that can't that see
their beautiful wife masha'allah but
can't do anything with her what happened
and bro there's another thing i talked
about with gabriel the assurance of
paternity bro women women subconsciously
they know biologically that this is my
kid 50 of the the heredity the genetic
material in the kid 50 of its mind a man
yeah okay we're not talking about today
you could do paternity tests we're not
talking about any of that i'm speaking
strictly subconsciously he has no
guarantee the surety of paternity
there's none so if you add four men into
that equation does that make sense
whereas if you have one man and four
women the man hundred percent knows that
fifty percent of the genetic material is
his he has assured paternity and all the
mothers they gave birth so of course
but do you guys have anything to say
before the last clip
just to say yeah
go ahead uh mama's baby daddy's maybe
[Music]
all right this is gonna be the most
horrendous clips i'm warning you guys
but
let's finish it so in this video i'll be
talking about
how to manage being a student and doing
only fans
so i guess the main thing would be about
time management and
because only fans actually does take a
lot of time and it is very time
consuming
so as you probably might not know i am a
mechanical engineering student at an ivy
league university obviously i'm not
going to say which one
but that also does come with a lot of
work so putting only fans on top of that
just does become a big hassle
so the main thing is that you should set
a schedule for yourself so i set a
schedule for myself like every time i go
to class um that's just like focusing on
my classwork and stuff like that and
then when i come back home i open only
fans and i talk with people and answer
messages and stuff like that
um so yeah i guess just the main thing
is about time management and setting
your priorities and once you have that
you can pretty much do anything you want
so hopefully that helps
that's it
that's it this video is done
i think that answers it all like
you you can't be a muslim and do only
fans stop what you're doing show her her
ankle bone
no she's showing a
a lot more than the ankle bone i bet you
that
she's talking to people
i don't know that's that's what she said
come on
like this is
i mind if i just go ahead and jump on
this one you know
i have to ask the question where are
where are the men folk of her family
you know um we have to wonder where her
brothers are her uncles her father
grandfather where are the men folk to
these women
and i'm not i'm not you know i don't
want to trash anybody i don't want to
make it seem like they're superior
people but you know i said this last
night you can't find the the women of
american online not
my family i'm the only muslim in my
family you won't find my sister who's a
non-muslim online on-only fans you won't
find it you won't find my mom my nieces
my cousins i watch them all we watch our
women folk and this is something we did
before we became muslim you will not
find
our women folk online and if you did we
would call them up and there would be no
mercy until she cut herself off from the
family or she stopped what she was doing
online you don't find them arguing with
men online you don't find them showing
their bodies online you don't find them
doing any dodgy stuff online if you find
them online at all where are her menfolk
we are people who have hira we have
protective jealousy over our women it's
an obligation but there should be this
natural this should be a ficture it
should be like your natural state and
condition as a man to have this where
other men where where are her men
i i
i'm speechless on this part yeah
100 percent
i mean as anna said that kind of like
wraps it up it was really funny at the
end how she basically said if you manage
your time right you could do whatever
you want it's like why are you such a
liberal like what you can do anything
you want really and even if it's haram
even if it's going to take you directly
to hell you can do anything you want now
as long as you manage your time
correctly
um
the prophet saws facing persecution
first facing ostracization bro facing
everything he faces on for so many years
bro just to propagate the dean of islam
only for a woman today
to do this role just think about it like
what have what has the and this is
assuming she's actually muslim what has
the ummah come to us
and and
you know in
actually you know
it's more common that they have only
fans in here but i don't know maybe this
is going to be a trend now but in the
kuffar they then shame the man for
having the
americans said
oh you don't trust me you're controlling
why can't i have only fans why can't i
do this you don't trust me
like you do you see the shaming tactics
they use bro
yeah that's disgusting
bro
i just i just wanna
give a sincere invitation to this woman
man like if she truly is muslim like
she's claiming she is
look we sincerely invite you to actually
study your religion
and reflect over your actions because
as of now like
speaking to you sincerely as a brother
like you are choosing
the akira oh no you're choosing the
dunya over the akhila
you you're choosing this temporary life
which i mean you could die tomorrow you
died today
i say like you're choosing
just to have money and you're choosing
your emotions and all this stuff and
again
like please like study your religion
reflect on it and
start making better choices because
what you're doing right now ain't it do
you know how much she makes a month from
only fans bro i read 60
a month bro and she no i'm saying she
makes 60 000 a month and she's claiming
she only talks to men
bro what man is gonna pay you this much
it makes no sense bro you're definitely
doing some haram stuff bro even being on
only fans to talk to women is haram yeah
many fans was made for that only fans
isn't a little chatting site it's not
like it's not like a
facebook messenger no only fans was made
to basically pimp out women like this
yeah yeah
did you say 60 16
60 000 600 bro you look at you look at
the dark side of the economic uh or the
finances of only fans there's
documentaries on this but they basically
wanted to lower the premium on women's
sexuality so they do this by starting
with it was 50 bro to subscribe to a
woman and then it's like 25 because
there's more women so they're basically
working at their insecurity and making
the the money the premium lower and
lower to the point where one day it's
gonna be like a dollar and there's gonna
be too many women competing and
what do you think this is doing to their
psyche bro they're already so like
mentally inferior in the in this in the
sense of security and self-esteem
because if you look there's too many
studies to prove that but you now let
them play at that insecurity
bro that's that's crazy i want to make
two final points inshallah i'm done
whatever price that she sent her only
fans out let's just say 25 whatever you
your body your sexuality is worth twenty
five dollars a month
think about that you are
you in a sexual manner is worth twenty
five dollars a month that's what you're
saying to everyone in the world
you and everyone else was on only fence
so you're worth x amount of money per
month that's that's vile honestly that's
violent there's no self-respect there if
that's what you think about yourself and
that's how you treat yourself uh that's
one two
if you're using this money which you
obviously are your food is haram your
drink is haram you're called
your house is haram you're living with
haram every dollar you spend every cent
you spend is haram you're going to be
questioned on every single penny that
you have
so i mean you might be living it up now
and thinking that you know life is good
whatever eventually you're going to die
i'm going to die we're all going to go
to allah i'm going to be questioning my
money what i did you're going to be
questioning what you did and
alhamdulillah insha allah will have this
channel as a testament for us may allah
accept it from us that we try to do good
you're going to have your tick tock and
your only fancy testament against you
and may allah protect us and guide you
you know um
i'll follow the trend there that you
call it a trend but you know it's this
proper way in advising her if you if you
consider yourself muslim um then i will
say sister
uh but if you're not muslim either way
this applies this is the religion of
islam and it's real you know whether you
believe it or not this is something that
when you die you are going to face a lot
you don't have to believe that for it to
be true
this religion is not your sales pitch it
is not your marketing strategy to gain
more followers and more money and more
income this is not this is not a game
this is not something you should try and
play with
you know i advise you sincerely to be
careful what you're doing don't don't
play with the religion of allah there's
a lot in the dunya there's a lot in the
world that you can play with this is not
one of the things that you should toy
around with
you know um because you're going to face
allah and when you do
he should
he he's severe and swift in retribution
you should be careful
next
understand that now this is this is me
as abu american speaking there's value
and there's worth to everything
and as our brothers have been saying you
have cheapened yourself you've learned
you've lowered yourself you've put a
price on yourself your dignity and your
honor as a woman women are made are born
men are made
we have to build ourselves as men and
make ourselves into something you have
an intrinsic value as a woman and that's
priceless
why do you cheapen it
only fans what you're doing is you're
saying i become accessible to the world
at a very low price
and it is a low price whether it's
twenty dollars fifty dollars a hundred
dollars it's a low price when you have
something that's priceless which is
access to yourself as a female
in any and every culture you look at on
the world
virginity uh uh
how you are seen or how much of you is
not seen has something that has a price
there was this king he he
there was i can't remember the story but
his wife rode through the city naked on
horseback and the rule was if anybody
opened and looked out they would be
killed this is how much he valued his
woman this is a true story apparently
some queen i can't remember was a
european queen
but you
you make yourself accessible to the
world cheaply
there's just no dignity in it whatsoever
in anything that you're doing right now
there's no dignity in it and i advise
you to just stop
yo
i got i got
i got a song bro
man
you said that it she's basically selling
herself very cheaply
right
i'd say she's
she's actually not even selling herself
because think about it
you have
only fans there is a price
for entrance
correct
but you have people who screen record
whatever it is that you put on
and now they put that on these websites
which i'm not even going to say with
these websites are and now everybody can
see it for free
so now she's basically giving
herself away for no price whatsoever
she went from priceless to worthless bro
no other way to say
truly
and when i say this guys i know there's
gonna be haram police i'm not talking
about her value in the eyes of allah or
her capability to repent i'm talking
about her sexuality and at least how she
values it bro and actions speak louder
than words bro for all you haram police
out there there i said it actually speak
louder than words you could say yeah bro
she might actually revert and allow my
lover more than you
okay but actions still speak louder than
words bro and until i see some action
and i keep seeing these cringy tick
tocks on our account i'm gonna say what
i have to say
yeah
i know i said the last two things i said
were gonna be the last ones but i have
to say this because it just you spark
something in me may allah bless you all
i mean
look at look at the islam that you bash
sister the islam that you bash let's
look what uh what islam says about a
woman and her value and all of that
stuff when it comes to like let's just
say intimacy and all that islam says if
you
are interested in a woman
you have to go to her father demonstrate
to her father that you are capable of
taking care of her and assuming that
role of protection and and obviously
that uh role that you take care of her
and he has to see that in you accept you
give his daughter in marriage to you and
you have to give her a gift that she and
you both are okay with that she says
okay i'm okay with this much money or
this gift or that gift or whatever
and
then and only then when the neca is done
in front of the community for everyone
to know you two are married and that you
are now her protector only then
only then
and only then
can you see any part of her other than
her face in her hands
versus
only fans
choose
one point if i had made you know um and
made a good point that you know um the
intern for the haram police the internet
doesn't forgive you know so if anybody
if anybody wants to i mean she can't
repent but do you want the wife
the only fan's wife because if you say
okay she could repent and all i could
see in a better view than you okay then
marry that sister if that if that's what
happens are you going to marry that
woman the only fans woman with her
videos online that someone scream
recorded
i twitter twitter still doesn't forgive
me for stuff that isn't even haram i
hear about stuff from two years ago on
twitter and they look it up and they
still try and attack me with it what do
you think is going to happen to this
woman when she marries a brother
you think they're going to let that go
yes a lot for gifts but people don't and
some of those people you're in the
comment sections right now so let's
let's be realistic you know on that
point and we and we wish the best for
her absolutely that you know and that's
from correction of her her current
situation for all of our situations to
improve inshallah
[Music]
and with that being said allah guide the
sister and all of us obviously it's an
attack on her so it's a critique of what
she's been saying and obviously some
certain industries out there but
with that being said allah
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
you